Hey, Phil really quickly before you go,
I hear you made quite an
interesting whittling project.
I just wanted to see
if we should see that.
I did. I've spent the,
the pandemic whittling
dicks into everything,
a wooden handle.
Sorry I asked.
And so, yeah
What, what?
I've just, and I've gotten
I've actually gotten pretty good.
Oh my God, there are veins.
Oh my God.
Wait a minute. Wait a minute, wait.
A great dick.
(laughs)
[Matt] Oh my God.
Sona, wait a minute.
It's a, it's very detailed.
Salt, pepper.
[Conan] But why are you-
Pepper grinder!
Phil, why are you, stop it! Phil!
I mean, nunchucks? Need nunchucks?
No way!
Oh my God!
[Matt] I don't need nunchucks
and I don't need dickchucks.
People have to check these out.
These are, you're making wooden dildos
that are quite realistic. And then
and you learned to whittle
these in your, during COVID?
That's right. I've taught
my, so I told my wife
I was gonna become an
artisan dick whittler.
I was gonna quit everything.
(laughing)
You, you-
Become an artisan and she didn't laugh,
which is, that means that
I'm gonna double down
and I'm gonna keep going as a joke.
Yes! When people don't laugh.
No.
Man, you're a good, you're,
you're a good student.
When people don't laugh,
you don't double down,
you triple down.
[Matt] No, don't throw
good dicks after bad.
(laughing)
Why did you bring this up
at the last second, Matt?
I didn't know! I didn't,
I was just prompted.
I didn't know what they were.
So, uh, wow, so, okay well-
I take back everything I said.
I, I blessed this man
and told him to go forth in my name.
And then at the last second
you're like, oh yeah,
and one other thing, I whittle
dicks in my spare time.
Phil the dick whittler!
Yeah, you're Phil, the dick whittler,
and you've got the Conan
O'Brien seal of approval.
You should put-
I already got it. No take backs.
[Conan] I know there's no taking back now.
You can now put on them
as seen-
(laughing)
Conan O'Brien approved!
And put that, put that,
thumbs up on it and then, wow.
Okay. Well, I changed my mind.
You're a terrible person and
we're never to speak again.
Well, at least we have
the title of this episode.
Phil the dick whittler.
Yes.
Yay.
[Conan] Yeah, people
will listen for 95% of it
and not know why it's called
Phil the dick whittler,
and then it's the big surprise ending.
All right, Phil, really nice to meet you.
Likewise.
Don't get any splinters.
We'll talk to you later.
Thank you so much.
[Matt] In the making or the using?
All right, take it, take it easy.
Take it easy, Matt.
That was, Jesus.
Thank you. That was really
funny, Phil. Thank you.
Thank you so much
[Conan] Yeah, good to meet you. Take care
Great to meet you.
(laughing)
Oh my God.